CALLING IT A DIRECT ATTACK ON
OUR DEMOCRACY.
FOR MORE ON A HOST OF TOPICS
FROM CAPITOL HILL, I’M JOINED BY
SENATE MAJORITY LEADER
MITCH McCONNELL.
SENATOR, THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE.
>> GLAD TO BE HERE.
>> Bret: WE WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THE BRETT KAVANAUGH HEARINGS AND
OTHER THINGS.
FIRST, I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT
THIS ANONYMOUS OP-ED IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
TITLED "I’M PART OF THE
RESISTANCE INSIDE THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION," SAID TO BE A
SENIOR TOP ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIAL.
ADDING, "IN THIS OP-ED, IT MAY
BE COLD COMFORT IN THIS CHAOTIC
ERA BUT AMERICANS SHOULD KNOW
THAT THERE ARE ADULTS IN THE
ROOM WHO FULLY RECOGNIZE WHAT IS
HAPPENING AND WE ARE TRYING TO
DO WHAT IS RIGHT, EVEN WHEN
DONALD TRUMP WON’T."
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS?
>> I HAD NOT SEEN THIS PIECE
UNTIL YOUR SET UP AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE SHOW, SO
THEREFORE I REALLY HAVE NOTHING
TO SAY ABOUT IT, OTHER THAN I
THINK IT’S IMPORTANT FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO KNOW, IF YOU
ARE ONE OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WHO ARE RIGHT OF CENTER, IT’S
BEEN AN EXTRAORDINARILY
PRODUCTIVE CONGRESS, FROM THE
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES, CIRCUIT
JUDGES, REGULATORY CHANGES, TAX
REFORM, WE HAD AN
EXTRAORDINARILY ACCOMPLISHED
CONGRESS, AND THAT’S WHAT OUR
MEETING AT THE WHITE HOUSE WAS
ABOUT, FINISHING UP THIS YEAR’S
PHYSICAL YOUR BUSINESS.
>> Bret: YOU DID MEET WITH THE
PRESIDENT TODAY, HOUSE SPEAKER
PAUL RYAN.
THIS OP-ED SUGGESTS THAT DESPITE
HIS LEADERSHIP STYLE, THESIS
SUCCESSES ARE HAPPENING.
YOU AGREE WITH THAT?
>> IT’S BEEN A GOOD TEAM.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
INTERESTED IN THE THINGS WE
WANTED TO PURSUE.
WE’VE BEEN ON THE SAME
WAVELENGTH ON ALL OF THOSE
ISSUES, TAXES, REGULATIONS,
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES, CIRCUIT
JUDGES, ALL THOSE ISSUES, WE’VE
BEEN IN THE SAME PLACE.
HE SIGNED THEM INTO LAW AND I
SAID, IF YOU ARE AN AMERICAN OUT
THERE WHO PREFERS THE COUNTRY
RIGHT OF CENTER, THERE HASN’T
BEEN A BETTER CONGRESS AND THE
TIME I’VE BEEN IN THE SENATE.
>> Bret: HE HAS ADDED TO, IN
THE WAKE OF THE BOB WOODWARD
BOOK AND HIS REACTION TO THAT,
THAT YOU HAVE THIS ANONYMOUS
OP-ED, YOUR INTERACTION TODAY?
>> WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
FINISHING THE PEOPLE’S BUSINESS
BEFORE THE END OF THE
FISCAL YEAR.
THREE CONFERENCE REPORTS AND
APPROPRIATION BILLS, SOUNDS
BORING TO YOUR AUDIENCE BUT
9 OUT OF 12 OF THOSE ARE SIGNED
INTO LAW BEFORE THE END
OF SEPTEMBER, THAT WILL NOT HAVE
HAPPENED SINCE 1997, OVER 20
YEARS AGO.
COMPLETING A FARM BILL.
AMERICA IN GENERAL IS IN GOOD
SHAPE.
AGRICULTURAL AMERICA IS NOT.
WE ARE INTENT ON FINISHING THIS
FARM BILL, GETTING IT SIGNED
BEFORE THE FARM BILL EXPIRES AT
THE END OF SEPTEMBER.
THOSE ARE THE THINGS THAT WE
WERE FOCUSING ON.
>> Bret: THE LAST THING ON
THIS, ARE YOU WORRIED THAT THERE
ARE PEOPLE INSIDE THIS
ADMINISTRATION THAT ARE
ESSENTIALLY TRYING TO BRING THIS
PRESIDENT DOWN?
>> MY JOB IS TO TRY TO ACHIEVE
AS MUCH OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AS I CAN.
THESE REPUBLICAN GOVERNMENTS
DON’T COME ALONG VERY OFTEN.
NOT MANY AMERICANS KNOW THIS BUT
WHEN YOU GO BACK 100 YEARS, ONLY
20 OF THE 100 YEARS TO THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY AT THE
WHITE HOUSE, HOUSE, AND CENTERED
AT THE SAME TIME.
WE DON’T WANT TO SQUANDER THAT
OPPORTUNITY.
I THINK WE’VE DONE A LOT FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND WE WILL DO A
LOT MORE BEFORE THE END OF THE
YEAR.
>> Bret: I DON’T WANT TO
BELABOR THIS POINT SO I WILL
MOVE ON, THERE WAS AN EFFORT BY
YOUR COUNTERPART,
SENATOR SCHUMER, TO KIND OF SLOW
THINGS UP ON THIS KAVANAUGH
HEARING.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> THE REPUBLICAN MAJORITY IS
DELIBERATELY OBSTRUCTING THE
SENATE’S CONSTITUTIONAL DUTY TO
FAIRLY AND THOROUGHLY CONDUCT
OUR ADVICE AND CONSENT POWERS.
SO --
>> ORDER IN THE CHAMBER.
>> AS A RESULT, WE WILL NOT
CONSENT TO BUSINESS AS USUAL ON
THE SENATE FLOOR TODAY.
>> Bret: NOT TO GET TOO MUCH
IN THE WEEDS, EXPLAIN WHAT I WAS
ABOUT.
>> HE WAS TRYING TO SHUTDOWN THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE HEARING.
WE SIMPLY ADJOURNED THE SENATE
TO PREVENT HIM FROM DOING THAT.
YOU’VE SEEN THE ATTICS AND
COMMITTEE, YOUR NETWORK HAS BEEN
CARING AT, ALL THE HOOTING AND
HOLLERING AND MISBEHAVIOR.
BUT NONE OF THAT HAS MAKING A
DIFFERENCE.
THE PRESIDENT NOMINATED AN
ALL-STAR.
I CAN RECOGNIZE A GREAT LAWYER
WHEN I SEE ONE.
BRETT KAVANAUGH IS A GREAT
LAWYER.
HE’S GOING TO BE CONFIRMED
BEFORE THE END OF SEPTEMBER AND
BE ON THE COURT WHEN IT STARTS
ITS NEXT SESSION THE FIRST
MONDAY IN OCTOBER.
>> Bret: SENATOR SCHUMER’S
POINT, THE COMPLAINT REALLY IS
BEEN UPHELD, SOME CAME OUT LATE,
BEEN UPHELD, SOME CAME OUT LATE4
BEEN UPHELD, SOME CAME OUT LATE0
ABOUT THE DOCUMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN UPHELD, SOME CAME OUT LATE.
SOME HAVE FALLING UNDER THE
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE FROM THE
BUSH AND ADMINISTRATION.
RESPONSE TO THAT COMPLAINT?
>> MORE PAPER HAS BEEN PRODUCED
FOR THIS NOMINEE THAN ANY
NOMINEE IN HISTORY.
WE HAVE 12 YEARS OF DECISIONS ON
THE D.C. CIRCUIT WHICH ARE
DIRECTLY RELATED TO HIS
NOMINATION.
EVERY ONE OF THESE PEOPLE
SCREAMING ABOUT GETTING MORE
PAPERS HAVE ALREADY ANNOUNCED
THEY WILL VOTE AGAINST HIM.
WHAT ELSE DO THEY NEED TO KNOW?
THEY ARE ALREADY AGAINST HIM.
THIS IS A SMOKE SCREEN.
WHEN YOU HEAR PEOPLE ARGUING
ABOUT PROCESS, YOU KNOW, THEY
GOT NOTHING ELSE.
WITH BRETT KAVANAUGH, THERE IS
REALLY NO GOOD ARGUMENT NOT TO
CONFIRM THAT.
>> Bret: YOU COMPLAIN, THOUGH,
BY THE DEMOCRATIC TACTICS,
PUSHING BACK AGAINST KAVANAUGH.
BUT WHAT ABOUT MERRICK GARLAND,
AND WOULDN’T YOU HAVE THROWN A
FIT OF DEMOCRATS TREATED A
G.O.P. NOMINEE THE WAY YOU
TREATED GARLAND?
>> LOOK, I WAS QUOTING JOE BIDEN
IN 1992, WHO SAID IF A VACANCY
OCCURRED IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION, THEY
WOULDN’T FILL IT.
DEMOCRATIC, SENATE, REPUBLICAN,
PRESIDENT.
CHUCK SCHUMER AND HARRY REID
SAID, 18 MONTHS BEFORE THE END
OF THE BUSH YEARS, IF A VACANCY
OCCURRED, AND A PRESIDENTIAL
YEAR, THEY WOULDN’T FILL IT.
I KNEW IF SHE WAS ON THE OTHER
FOOT, AND WE HAD A VACANCY
NOMINATING A REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENT TO A DEMOCRATIC SENATE
AND THE MIDDLE OF A PRESIDENTIAL
YEAR, THEY WOULDN’T FILL IT.
LISTEN, THAT WAS SIMPLY NOT
GOING TO HAPPEN.
I SAID, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
TO WEIGH IN ON THIS LIFETIME
APPOINTMENT, AND WHOEVER THEY
CHOSE, MOST PEOPLE THOUGHT IT
WAS GOING TO BE HILLARY CLINTON.
WHOEVER WAS BEING ELECTED IN THE
MIDDLE OF THAT HERE OUGHT TO
MAKE THAT DECISION.
THAT IS WHAT HAPPENED.
THE DEMOCRATS LOST.
>> Bret: YOU KEPT THE SENATE
AND SESSION FOR PART OF AUGUST
TO HANDLE SPENDING BILLS AT THE
PRESIDENT’S REQUEST.
YOU MADE THE MOST PROGRESS, AS
YOU MENTIONED, AND SPENDING
BILLS IN 20 PLUS YEARS.
WHY WOULDN’T THE PRESIDENT OR TO
THOSE UP BECAUSE THERE IS NO
MONEY FOR A WALL?
IS THAT STILL A POSSIBILITY THAT
THIS THING ALL COMES CRASHING TO
A HALT?
>> NO, THE NINE BILLS WE WILL
PUT ON HIS DESK BEFORE THE END
OF SEPTEMBER, WHICH IS THE END
OF THE FISCAL YEAR, DEAL WITH
OTHER SUBSTANCE.
BUT IT ALSO, 90% OF THE FEDERAL
BUDGET, WILL HAVE BEEN APPROVED
BEFORE THE END OF THE
FISCAL YEAR.
AS HE POINTED OUT, THAT HADN’T
HAPPENED SINCE 1997.
WE STILL ARE IN FAVOR OF THE
WALL, WE STILL WANT TO GET
FUNDING FOR THE WALL, BUT WE
THINK
♫
♫ ♫
>> Bret: A FOX NEWS ALERT.
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP IS NOT
FINISHED COMMENTING ON
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" ANONYMOUS
BED.
HE MADE SOME STATEMENTS EARLIER
BUT NOW JUST TWEETING ONE WORD
WITH A QUESTION MARK.
"TREASON"?
OBVIOUSLY REFERRING TO WHOEVER
WROTE THAT OP-ED.
WE ARE HERE THE SENATE MAJORITY
LEADER.
TREASON?
>> I DON’T HAVE ANY OBSERVATION
TO MAKE ON THIS EPISODE.
>> Bret: LAST THING.
I MEAN, FOR SOMEONE TO WRITE AND
TO BE QUOTED IN BOB WOODWARD’S
ELSE PERHAPS, THE ROOT OF THE PO
ELSE PERHAPS, THE ROOT OF THE PL
ELSE PERHAPS, THE ROOT OF THE PM
ELSE PERHAPS, THE ROOT OF THE PI
ELSE PERHAPS, THE ROOT OF THE PS
ELSE PERHAPS, THE ROOT OF THE PT
ELSE PERHAPS, THE ROOT OF THE PE
ELSE PERHAPS, THE ROOT OF THE PP
ELSE PERHAPS, THE ROOT OF THE PI
ELSE PERHAPS, THE ROOT OF THE PE
ELSE PERHAPS, THE ROOT OF THE PT
BOOK AND TO THEN WRITE SOMEONE
ELSE PERHAPS, THE ROOT OF THE PS
AMORALITY, IS NOT A PROBLEM FOR
THIS ADMINISTRATION?
>> LOOK, I WOULD LIKE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO JUDGE THE
RESULTS THAT WE HAVE ACHIEVED IN
THE LAST TWO YEARS AND WE ARE
NOT THROUGH AND I WOULD LIKE TO
FOCUS ON OUR ACCOMPLISHMENTS, OF
WHICH I THINK THERE ARE AN
ENORMOUS NUMBER.
>> Bret: NO CHANCE, GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN?
>> NO CHANCE OF A GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN.
>> Bret: ZERO?
>> ZERO.
>> Bret: IN MARCH, THE
PRESIDENT THREATENED NOT TO SIGN
THE OMNIBUS BILL AT THE LAST
MINUTE, EVEN THOUGH HE HAD
NEGOTIATED IT.
DO YOU WORRY THAT YOU MAY HAVE
AN AGREEMENT ON GOVERNMENT
SPENDING AND THEN YOU DON’T?
>> I DON’T WORRY ABOUT THAT.
WE HAD A GOOD DISCUSSION TODAY.
I EXPECT HIM TO SIGN THESE NINE
BILLS INTO LAW.
THAT WILL FUND 90% OF THE
GOVERNMENT FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
20 YEARS, BEFORE THE END OF THE
FISCAL YEAR.
THEN I EXPECT US TO DO A SHORT
TERM CONTINUE RESOLUTION FOR THE
BALANCE OF THE FUNDING AND THEN
HAVE THAT DISCUSSION ABOUT HOW
TO FUND THE WALL AFTER THE
ELECTION.
>> Bret: HAS THE SHIP SAILED
ON REPEAL AND REPLACE OBAMACARE?
NOW YOU HAVE SENATOR JOHN      J
NOW YOU HAVE SENATOR JOHN      N
NOW YOU HAVE SENATOR JOHN      K
NOW YOU HAVE SENATOR JOHN      L
NOW YOU HAVE SENATOR JOHN      I
ON REPEAL AND REPLACE OBAMACARE?
NOW YOU HAVE SENATOR JOHN      N
THE POSITION OF THE LATE
SENATOR JOHN McCAIN, WHO VOTED
NO ON THAT.
SENATOR KYL PERHAPS WOULD VOTE
YES.
AS REPEAL AND REPLACE, THAT SHIP
GONE FOR THIS YEAR?
>> FOR THIS CONGRESS, IT WOULD
BE DIFFICULT TO ACHIEVE.
I THINK WHETHER WE CAN ACHIEVE
IT LATER DEPENDS UPON THE
RESULTS THIS FALL AND THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE A CHANCE TO
DECIDE WHAT KIND OF CONGRESS
THEY WANT TO HAVE COMING INTO
THE NEXT TWO YEARS.
>> Bret: WHAT ARE REPUBLICANS
RUNNING ON?
IT DOESN’T SEEM LIKE A TOTALLY
UNIFIED MESSAGE.
IS THERE ONE?
>> I THINK THE ECONOMY.
IT’S A RED-HOT ECONOMY.
THE POLICIES OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION AND CONGRESS HAVE
MADE A HUGE DIFFERENCE, WHETHER
IT IS TAX REFORM OUR REGULATORY
RELIEF.
THE COUNTRY IS BOOMING.
THESE ARE RECORD NUMBERS THAT WE
ARE PRODUCING, UNEMPLOYMENT,
GROWTH, THAT MAKES A HUGE
DIFFERENCE IN THE LIVES OF
PEOPLE ALL ACROSS OUR NATION.
THAT IS A RESULT OF THIS
REPUBLICAN GOVERNMENT.
WE THINK WE HAVE PLENTY TO IRAN,
NOT TO MENTION THE FACT WE ARE
TRANSFORMING THE COURTS, TWO
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES, 26 NEW
CIRCUIT JUDGES, MAKING A
DIFFERENCE IN THE LIVES OF EVERY
LITIGANT TO THE COUNTRY WHEN
THEY GO    GO TO COURT.
>> Bret: THE PRESIDENT HAS NOT
BEEN SHY ABOUT TALKING AND
TWEETING ABOUT HIS
ATTORNEY GENERAL, JEFF SESSIONS,
WHO YOU KNOW VERY WELL, HAS BEEN
VERY AGGRESSIVE IN RECENT DAYS
ON THAT FRONT.
THE PRESIDENT JUST TODAY WAS
ASKED ABOUT IT.
HE SAID THIS.
"I HOLD JEFF SESSIONS IN THE
HIGHEST REGARD, I APPRECIATE HIS
SERVICE TO THE NATION."
ARE YOU WITH VICE PRESIDENT
PENCE OR PRESIDENT TRUMP ON
THIS?
>> I CAN SPEAK FOR MYSELF, I’M A
HUGE SUPPORTER OF JEFF SESSIONS,
I THINK IS DONE A GREAT JOB AND
I HOPE HE STAYS WHERE HE IS.
>> Bret: YOU THINK HE WILL?
>> WE’LL FIND OUT.
>> Bret: WE JUST FINISHED THE
MEMORIAL SERVICES FOR
JOHN McCAIN.
TELL US ABOUT YOUR LAST
CONVERSATION WITH
SENATOR McCAIN AND YOUR
EMOTIONS AS THIS WEEK CAME TO AN
END.
>> I WENT OUT TO SEE HIM IN MAY.
WE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO RELIVE
OLD BATTLES, WE WERE ON THE
OPPOSITE SIDE OF MANY, MANY
ISSUES, AND THEN ON THE SAME
SIDE OF OTHERS.
I WAS PLEASED I HAD A CHANCE TO
SAY GOODBYE.
JOHN LOVED A GOOD VIBE THAT I
DID, TOO.
WE HAD A PRETTY GOOD ONE THAT
WENT ON FOR TEN YEARS AND ENDED
UP IN THE SUPREME COURT.
WE EXPRESSED OUR LOVE FOR EACH
OTHER.
>> Bret: CAMPAIGN FINANCE,
OBVIOUSLY >> OUR LOVE FOR EACH
OTHER, AND IT WAS A PERFECT WAY
TO SAY GOODBYE.
>> Bret: WRAPPING THIS UP,
SPENDING, FARMVILLE, OPIOID
PREVENTION, FAA AUTHORIZATION?
>> I THINK WE ARE STRONG TO HAVE
A BIPARTISAN OPIOID BILL.
WE WILL GET FAA AUTHORIZATION